pour la première fois de son histoire le
concours de beauté miss france va
accueillir une candidate transgenres
première fois qu'une tranche jean des
buts la sélection pour prog les concours
de miss france
une participation qui rentrent dans les
termes du nouveau règlement mis en place
cette année on demande à ce que
l'identité civile soit féminin rendra
plus restera donc la première candidate
rangeant à se présenter au concours miss
ile de france qui se déroulera le 19
juin prochain l'actrice de 19 ans qui
avait été notamment révélé dans le
téléfilm il est elle qui parle justement
de la transidentité va donc concourir
pour la couronne je suis né dans le
mauvais corps alors une candidate
rangers se présente pour la toute
première fois au concours une bonne
chose
[Musique]
6 applaudissements dirais qu'on a un
césar à chaque fois ci on dit merci il
ya carla d'être avec nous cette journée
cette journaliste alain correct c'est ça
c'est à dire que c'est beaucoup de
cheveux singer beaucoup de choses mais
en grande partie à la corde raide à
l'accord avec 13 ans correct bah non en
fait je voulais mon siège n'ont rien à
[ __ ] de monde parce que moi j'ai pas
de pancartes et c'est mon rêve d'avoir
une banquette à laisser faire les
banques
alors prenez celle de tisser qui sert à
rien
montiel c'est très bien voilà mes soeurs
et à son reconnaissons au centre son
avis des gens s'en foutent sens je suis
content de le voir c'est l'atout
physique de l'émission va pas se mentir
non mais c'est vrai que là ton physique
de mission dont vous faites rien au fait
des beaux sourires et c'est ça la fait
déposer vous fermez votre gueule et tout
le monde sera content fait trente hommes
cette magnifique non mais sans déconner
fait 38 ans mais toi tu dois ta carrière
à ton physique à mon sort et est beau
comme un coeur un message non mais c'est
vrai regardez comme il est beau moi je
pense ont un âge
a toujours été bon ouais c'est vrai
c'est fou mais non mais c'est gentil
dire ça mais pas à mon âge pas plus
maintenant quoi
écoute moi bien si je trouve une
personne qui n'était pas bon certes
battus ou l'envoi brutale et dégueulasse
l'italie fait péter la gueule
du gentil ce catalan est vraiment petite
fille ou non pardon visite oui ou non
je dis oui non
alors bye à carla merci d'être là non
mais c'est important
19h56 je trouve cette question est ce
que cette question une candidate
transgenres se présente pour la première
fois au concours une bonne chose à et la
question par direct alors je voudrais
d'abord des oui et après lui avoir des
noms c'est le principe de l'émission
béatrice bien le nom comme ça je
voudrais d'abord un oui je voudrais hugo
manos merci le meilleur moyen de lutter
contre une phobie c'est d'éduquer les
gens et le problème dans ce dans ce cas
de figure c'est que on entend très
rarement parler des personnes
transgenres et là pour la première fois
potentiellement la voie d'une 30 joueurs
va être écoutés c'est à miss france pour
sa fille je termine mon propos si tu
veux quand même bien sûr et plaisir donc
moi je trouve que c'est vraiment une
excellente chose en plus elle est très
jolie moi j'attends qu'une chose c'est
qu'elle puisse s'exprimer pour qu'elle
nous parle un petit peu de sa différence
et puis quelle qu'elle éduque un peu les
gens pour qu'ils acceptent mieux les
femmes transgenres alors bonne à carla
alors moi il ya trop de points sur
lesquels
j'aimerais j'aimerais échanger les
éléments dit si tu étais pas c'est déjà
sur les règles direct de miss france je
croyais donc quand on veut postuler pour
pour pour se présenter à miss france il
ya déjà le la question de est ce que on
est une femme
ça c'est une grande question c'est
peut-être hors sujet mais en tout cas
moi je pense que non parce qu'il ya
plein de 2,2 comment dire de d'études
qui ont été établis et ça prouve que ce
n'est pas une femme déjà 1 6
on dit que normalement on est pas tous
avoir fait de la chirurgie sauf si elle
et réparatrice bon la matrice la sarre
et par desalle et par quoi ça répare le
ton est particulièrement intolérants
lâcheront pas vraiment le tout mais
vraiment c'est un
jugement de valeur c'est juste que ça un
sujet suprême important des boisés pas
d'unité mais comment
va-t-on soi même dans les importants
c'est le sait la communication que ça
fait là dessus sur les jeunes filles qui
veulent se présenter on parle pas de la
boucherie qui est faite sur ces
transgenres ou pas les passions mais
vous savez ce que c'est de tenir à jour
la promotion on en fait toujours
attention comme ici
le parcours d'une personne
blessée mais vous savez les traitements
donnés vous fait sur ces gens là où tu
parleras après vous savez les
traitements hormonaux c'est leur choix
mais bien sûr mais ces dons série gêne
et il faut absolument intégrer ce qui
domine ici il va seulement je trouve
absolument en parler c'est aussi
important c'est c'est pas c'est pas on
dit sûr de devenir un homme c'est très
différent si vous dérange aussi c'est
qu'il ya des règles dans mr en ce que
vous dites vous avez été nommé moi
c'était une idée en fait on s'est tous
posé la question quand on était une
jeune fille je pense que toi tu perds
moi je moi je suis posé la question oui
bon
on s'est posé la question si au début je
me suis fait circoncire sedan lever tous
passés mais voilà alors oui et donc oui
mais je me suis posé la question et j'ai
été réalisées sur internet et j'ai vu qu
étant donné que je faisais un mètre
soixante deux c'était pas possible j'ai
la taille minimum sahara m 75 pèse
bêtise chasse
en 2010 112 x donc voila moi je trouve
ça injuste
pour les femmes qui veulent se présenter
qui ne peuvent pas et donc si on doit
être dans la totale
comment dire tout à l'ouverture dans ces
cas là on accepte les femmes qui n'ont
pas la taille requise que ça je suis
d'accord
sur ce point là mais on n'est pas obligé
de détruire une un autre type de femmes
qui sont les femmes transgenres et j'ai
dès son arrivée pas des femmes non parce
que vous avez un désir qui est hyper
accablant pour les roms a toujours les
mêmes battus même guillon j'entends qui
dit non je voudrais avoir un autre nom
c'est une bonne nouvelle mais ce qui me
gêne c'est que ce n'est pas sincère en
fait tout ça reprenne re fait penser à
une énorme opération de communication et
de marketing de la part de tf1 du comité
miss france pour que miss france perde
un peu son image sexiste et réac
regarder le timing des événements en
septembre 2020 ils sortent un film sur
une miss transgenres avec sylvie tellier
dedans en 2021 ils sortent un fini les
ailes avec andrea furet dedans sylvie
telle il a annoncé son départ donc
forcément ça marque une rupture et line
nous annonce que la même actrice de ce
film va être candidates on sait qu'elle
va gagner miss paris on sait qu'elle va
gagner miss ile de france moi ça n'a pas
l'air sincère c'est juste pour
commission se perdre son côté on y avoir
c'est celle ci s'était invitée lié qu'à
prononcer elle avait dit voilà moi
j'imaginerais pas qu'une miss
transgenres pour être élue miss france
ne l'arrêtera
cevital y est c'est la nouvelle
production veulent marquer une rupture
avec l'ancien hangar où là on a appelé
les producteurs de miss france alexia
laroche joubert a dit il n'y a pas de
sujet pour nous il n'y a aucun sujet
voilà donc c'est la réponse voilà la
réponse béatrice alors moi non tour 2
rbd chérie je vous dis on va avoir des
oui mais parce que comme on est tous
plus soumis il faudra marquer non voilà
pour voir pourquoi ils disent non aux
deux oui on sait pourquoi on dit mais
moi j'avais un truc sur l'accès à leur
11e battu le dire après quand tu as
manqué pour moi il ya deux points
premier point je rejoins madame dans le
sens où tout concourt à des critères on
respecte les critères forcément dès
qu'il ya des critères il ya
discrimination c'est à dire moi je suis
trop petit intel sera trop grosse voilà
et c'est donc il ya des critères on
respecte les critères on peut peut-être
faire un autre concours
moi je serai juste finir sur mon
deuxième point je commence à en avoir
moi personnellement marque on met de la
politique et du militantisme monique
ousmane
cissé des lyrics leur obésité aux
logiques bien sûr que oui si tu veux
mais elle sans un mot de sa bouche
monsieur rappaz demande de réciter pas
manquer de respect à des dizaines de
ménages éventail de l'udpci sont qui
sont ici or ce n'est pas du tout même si
vous attaquez toujours mais c'est
toujours les mêmes en cédant mais c'est
de vous en faites vous n'avez pas d'art
du monde donc vous m'attaquez vous
parlais mal man parce qu'une partie
générale je trouve qu'on rentre on met
de la politique dans tout l'ukraine a
gagné l'eurovision parce que à cause de
la guerre dans tous les sujets dans tous
les concours maintenant il faut que ce
soit engagé il faut que ce soit militant
et moi j'aimerais juste voir des espaces
un peu plus neutre et vous n'êtes pas
d'accord mais en tout cas c'est mon avis
et je pense qu'il ya beaucoup de gens
comme moi qui en ont assez d'avoir du
militantisme et des événements récupérés
par des engagements en quoi ça dérange
si c'est elle qui gagne tunis paris en
fait c'est ce que service parce qu'en
fait aujourd'hui la chaîne aujourd'hui
c'est donc c'est une stud c'est
considéré comme un drame auquel ce
qu'elle remplit tous les critères baril
pour participer à miss france alexia
laroche-joubert cantal est arrivé a
ouvert c'est la première mesure sa
première initiative cl8 elin ne voulait
pas être tout de suite il ya quelques
mois elle a dit pourquoi pas c'est à
dire que miss france suit l'évolution de
la société moi je trouve ça formidable
bon alors je vais vous dire je peux vous
dire sur les réseaux c'est très partagés
oui il ya beaucoup de gens qui sont
d'accord et oui c'est sûr qu'à 12 ans
qui sont plutôt d'accord avec nous mais
c'est plutôt partagés après la réponse
il n'y a pas de débat n'est pas de sujet
qu'est ce que vous en pensez ce que vous
en pensez bailat carla sur quelques
questions sur la production qu'il n'y a
pas de sujet là dessus ben non moi je
trouve qu'il ya un sujet au contraire il
faudrait demander l'avis des français
pour moi c'est ce qui compte alors la
vie des sens et on va le demander oui
mais voilà ce qu il est tentant de le
demander on va la voir dans un instant
cependant déjà un premier un premier
voilà une première idée sur le sondage
voila voila merci deux premières
tendances non est ce une bonne chose
donc très bon port sans l'égaler
[Applaudissements]
c'est incroyable je croyais pas 80% fin
après moi je pense que la voilà le
concours miss france i c'est très bien
d'ouvrir
mais je pense que quand on touche trou à
des règles
mais les gens de tout âge tout ça non
c'est n'importe quoi moi
c'est différent ça cartonne faut pas
trop changé je peux vous dire la vérité
oui juste revenir sur le système de vous
ce que vous parliez de critères non mais
il ya un critère et vous évoquiez la
greater elle elle répond à tous les
critères elle répond à tous les critères
puisque j'avais ma chance je peux
terminer je vous en remercie beaucoup
vous évoquiez la chirurgie il s'agit pas
ici d'une chirurgie esthétique mais je
considère là qu'il s'agit d'une forme de
chirurgie réparatrice puisqu'elle n'est
pas né dans le bon corps donc moi à
partir du moment où cette jeune femme
est une femme justement il n'y a plus de
sujets il n'y a plus de question c'est à
dire que elle va concourir comme les
autres elle répond par ailleurs à tous
les autres critères elle n'est pas
tatoué elle n'est pas mariée elle est
passée ce n est pas cela normal alors on
va demander moi je voudrais plein de
tweets l'âge ou le délire dans un
instant continue à réagir et vous allez
voir pourquoi les gens ne sont pas
d'accord ils sont 80% me contre d'autres
pas moi je vous dit sylvie tellier
c'était la gardienne du temps dans le de
miss france sylvie 120 ça va partir en
cacahuète et je vais vous dire ça va
être une catastrophe il ya une forme
d'hypocrisie là dedans en fait je vous
donnais une info en fait on a le droit
d'être une candidate 30 jan sa miss
france depuis toujours le règlement jeu
des six nations arctiques de points il
faut pas être né femme il faut être
inscrits à l'état civil des mines a donc
ça ne date pas d'hier et pourquoi le
comité miss france ne le faisais pas
assez vite et les expriment l'expliqué
très bien elle disait que les gens
n'étaient pas prêts à élire une liste
rangeant et que ça pouvait et
apparemment c'est une réalité quand on
voit les sondages et les propos de
certaines personnes que ça pouvait
choquer des gens de voir qu'on met en
avant des personnes transgenres en prime
est noire de monde et firewire le
téléfilm de tf1 n'avait pas du tout
marché à l'époque parce qu'il ya
certaines personnes moi je le combats
mais qui pensent que voilà c'est on ne
peut pas trop mettre en avant ce type de
personne et ça c'est une réalité qu'il
faut qu'il ne faut pas nier ces primes
est ce que tu penses que miss france est
en déficit de notoriété parce qu'on est
pas la même ça cartonne
car il souffre d'une image besoin de ça
pour souffler sur image sexiste et réac
et de tous ces critères pas trop petit
pas trop grosse pas de 30 jours et s'est
donc ils veulent s'ouvrir pour changer
leur image et c'est je pense qu'ils font
pour les mauvaises nasa lori la vie d'un
faux pas 30 je voulais rappeler qu'en
décembre 2021 laroche joubert qui est
présidente comme vous le savez de la
société miss france avait déclaré aucun
problème à ce qu'une candidate trans se
présente au concours bourse actuel on
casse le cul ouais
c'est ça alors mais voilà merci alors
j'ai toujours une petite pancarte bahia
carla toi ça te dérange et et tu as vu
qu'ils avaient 80 % des gens que ça des
roches moi je sais pas pourquoi alors
sais pas pourquoi ça dérange et donc
j'allais voir des tweets et je vous en
dira quelques-uns dans ce cas dans ce
cas là pourquoi ne pas mettre des femmes
voilées pour faire évoluer les
consciences mais oui mais abandonnée
quand il s'efforçait le noyer dedans
doigt mais de l'ennemi en vertu de mini
châteaux échantillons c'est sûr
rv parfaire ses 50 ans que ce soit
suffisamment femme sans poitrine c'est
de la chirurgie réparatrice au vin un
petit peu changé de sexe au rayon la
place aux deux curseurs cyril hanouna
ils nous ont merdé pour le maillot deux
pièces hélas pas d'opérations
esthétiques moins d'un euro 70 se
recaler et là c'est normal monde de fou
on a co organisé un concours pas pour ça
ou alors je veux bien un petit peu mais
tellement d'autres là derrière la tête
et mon d'autres mecheri merci
franchement c'est nimp abama ça va très
vite
c'est pas une femme il subit il a subi
un traitement hormonal et s'est fait
opérer ça fait pas de lui une femme ça
reste biologiquement un homme point
barre il n'a pas sa place dans ce
concours que je vous réponde à ça ça
c'est nouveau c'est ça c'est faux c'est
officiellement faux puisque les femmes
transgenres sont de leur état civil ce
sont des femmes et je voudrais juste
s'il vous plaît rappelez parce que je
crois que vous êtes proche de d'eric
zemmour qui avait du coup dit que en
effet les femmes transgenres ou les
amarres alors eric zemmour isin et
bernard montiel méné n'existait pas et
en tout cas que il était le fruit d'une
lubie ou d'une mode le parcours d'une
personne transgenre il est il est très
difficile il ya des psychologues des
opérations la stigmatisation la société
fins et des personnes qui souffrent
beaucoup d'ailleurs le taux de suicide
est très important oui je commette ce
n'est pas un effet de mode personnes par
mode avec 13 4 à 10 ans la défense
devient
son père eric zemmour je pense que ça
doit bon voilà déjà
mais c'est pas une accusation s excuse
peut-être que je me trompe mais c'est
pas le même des bons pour parler si
c'est pas
beau c'est mon côté berbère sinon ce que
je voulais dire c'est je suis totalement
d'accord avec sur les dangers que vous
avez évoquées et pour moi il faut en
parler c'est très important on n'en
parle pas assez et donc ce qui fait
qu'il ya des adolescents qui s'empilent
en pleine crise d'adolescence qui ont
qui pensent que c'est facile de changer
il serait temps d une personne ne pense
à marie bellot et moi mais je suis
impressionné jamais gêné dans le marais
vous êtes vous êtes plus d'ambition
je n'ai pas brandir la photo de marie
noirci
sais pas si j'ai apprécié pardonnez moi
que vous n'êtes plus dans une posture
idéologique dans une sorte de réalité
drôles sont vélizy ce nom mais
pardonnez moi quand vous dites par
exemple que du jour au lendemain un
garçon dont une jeune fille de 14 ans va
se dire horrifiant site mada larsen ne
fut dites moi vous peut toucher des
dollars
mais c'est vrai là c'est trop qui
comprend la troïka 24 j'ai décroché
mon cas mais vous ont désigné un peu la
baisse pour dino des trucs qu'on
comprend pour revenir à miss france
maintient mme henry mais je comprends
que les gens soient choqués pourquoi
pourquoi que parce que miss france qui
était un peu ringardisé tente de se
refaire une virginité de changer son
image un peu sur le dos de cette
candidate range alors pour faire du buzz
et donc moi je comprends les gens parce
que miss france ça représente une sorte
d'élégance à la française bouchra
question avec civilité liste est très
classe l'élégance à désolé 16gb tdc
l'élégance à la française toutes les
lignes de métier c'est l'élégance à la
france il faut dire que nous laissera
élégance à la française mais il faut
dire que nous souvent parisien voilà on
est on est on est plus ouvert que plein
de gens qui se dit je ne veux pas que
mon concours de miss france change et il
faut les entendre les informer non mais
oui mais il faut les informer mais faut
les entendre que le pape
les jeunes ne veulent pas que ça
j'aurais quand même qu'on est là la vie
d'une ancienne candidate
daniel
vas-y mehmedi lorsque tu en penses
thomas schleich que je la trouve
magnifique mais ça me gêne à plusieurs
égards c'est en fait de regarder comme
on est divisé et je pense que c'est pas
le lieu une élection miss france d'être
divisés
justement les votes se met ça va devenir
un peu politique entre guillemets elle
n'a pas complètement tort béatrice et
donc moi je pensais et puis et puis
excuse-moi hugo mais c'est pas là
qu'elle va pouvoir vraiment s'exprimer
sur la cause ils disent de phrases donc
c'est pas la confiance et recel
le pas laissés par les mamies la dre
comme ray pour moi c'est le jour une
candidate que très magnifique comme ça
se présentera et qu'on nomme on en
pleurerait
chroniques et leurs jours ne sont pas
testés jamais dit
vous m'appelez dit c'est pour ça
j'applaudis la police et je voulais dire
c'est que est ce que cette personne
représente le drapeau lgbt ou le drapeau
français c'est une vraie question alors
moi je la comprends pas justement elle
va aller
voter
on lan cap au caire pour présenter julie
non je reviens sur ce qu'a dit sauf qu'a
dit daniel et qui me semble très
intéressant en disant qu'il faudrait qu
on arrive à un jour à ce que ce ne soit
plus un sujet mais pour 15 jours ça ne
soit plus un sujet soit bien qu'à une
première première et là je pense que
c'est pas le lieu au mistral au lieu
qu'on organise des débats on fait plein
de choses il ya eu des téléfilm très
bien fait très poignant on a eu des
témoignages ici de deux femmes qui est
qui et pour qui c'était réussi et bien
dans leur peau tout ça c'est très bien
et c'est ça qui va faire évoluer aller
directement à elle représente la france
et que ça divise moi je ne suis pas
d'accord ce sont des femmes un postier
veulent ce sont des médailles en
ces moments l'info brute thrombolytique
mais c'est ça va pas en fait vraiment
esquiva particulier en fait il ya plus
il va pas là-bas yaakaar ya vingt-six
communication sur les dangers ou si
c'est ça que j'aimais vous mais vous
rigolez ou quoi je ne les énumérer ça
mais pardonnez moi même alors laissez
pas finir parce que j'avais vu la mer je
comprends rien
changement de sexe oui en son genre je
pense la demoiselle que calquer
inquiétant dans un chemin pour changer
de sexe et les connaît et il les connaît
même dit au pare brise est un business
séparé les antennes jeunes
hommes qu'une jeune femme qui se
retrouve sur un billard à 45 reprises un
plaisir de se retrouver sur le billard
une fois qu'ils sont guéris on se remet
engagé un moment en guerre et il voit
parfois une formule est en marche
arrière des déficits c'est bien mais
vous rigolez ou quoi
bedie ciel helvétique pour entamer pour
entamer une transition un psychiatre
doit valider ça dure des mois voire des
années je serais intéressé vous
reprocher c'est super je me sentirai
outils c'est l'histoire de deux jeunes 7
6 4 de la rime allaf